one more piece of follow-up this is the
question I posed to you and I said what
does this look like okay now there's an
easy way and there's a hard way to do
this hard ways would be okay let's try
out some values right because that's the
way you did the original function
another hard way would be the same hmm
okay I wonder if I can like do some
differentiation and things like that
which some of you already know the rest
of you will learn today the easy way is
always in maths you've known abstract so
much about solving problems is taking a
problem that you do not know and trying
to phrase it in terms of something you
do know that we leave it over what this
looks like we know what it looks like
how can you express this in those terms
the answer is what is this like what is
its cosine it's code sine cosine gets
its definition from sine right
specifically cos x what's it equal to in
terms of side it's sign of well we want
the complement don't we
that's the compliment isn't it okay so
therefore his toppling should be sine
inverse of sine that right okay now how
does that relate to that there are two
changes aren't there one of the two
changes number one there's a phase shift
because this thing unlike this does have
phase okay and number two there's a
reflection now the funny thing is when
you reflect something like this because
of the symmetry right it ends up looking
very similar okay but there you go
that's enough pieces it's still gonna be
that kind of jagged linear sort of thing
but it's going moved over and reflected
okay today's relation you can work it
out as you like